we'll talk about kitchen decisions
convicts low-rank my ethics of the
musicians okay well thank you guys for
all coming back here after when there's
like coffee and snacks outside so I'm
gonna talk about work this is joint work
with LP river and Vulcan sever at EPFL
and you'll chop at Caltech so let's get
started so here's the basic problem that
we were motivated by don't let's suppose
that we've got a convex optimization
problem and we're gonna suppose that the
problem has a compact representation so
here I'm gonna say that means that I can
write down the problem using order and
floating-point numbers and I'm also
gonna suppose that I happen to know that
I can represent the solution also using
order and floating-point numbers so I've
got some extra site information or who
knows what we'll see a lot of examples
but the question is how much memory does
it take me to solve this problem do I do
I need I mean those clearly I need at
least order and memory because I have to
be able to read in the data and I have
to be able to write out the solution but
are there some cases where I might need
more than order and memory or can I
always get away with order and memory I
mean that's that's clearly the minimum
can I always achieve it right so we want
to be able to solve any convex
optimization problem using memory that's
bounded by the by the size of the
problem data and the size of the
solution
so I'm not gonna solve this book I'm
like right most people they protect a
question and then they answer that
question and I'm very sorry I can't
answer this question for you right now
but I'm gonna answer a related question
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
stick to a subclass of problems that I
think has interesting structure so here
we're going to consider a optimization
problem convex optimization problem with
a matrix decision variable so an M by n
rectangular decision variable and the
problems we're going to be looking at
are problems of this form we're gonna
minimize some function of a linear map
applied to that matrix a linear map a
applied to the matrix X subject to a
constraint on the shat in one norm of X
so the sum of the singular values of X
right also known as the trace
norm also known as the nuclear norm I'm
going to try to keep referring to a
dislike shopping one norm just to be
consistent and we're supposing that this
function f is convex and smooth and I
guess it's also going to be pretty
important right so we're taking this
linear map on X and it's gonna remember
sort of D things about this matrix X and
then we are objective depends only on
those d things that we remembered about
our matrix x so for this to be a compact
matrix optimization problem we're gonna
assume that both the specification in
the solution are compact which means the
problem data will use order n storage so
what's the problem data it's this linear
map a and this function f then I guess
the scale or alpha but that's no problem
from the storage perspective and in the
solution so one way that we could be
sure that we could represent the
solution in order n would be if the rank
of the solution was some constant R
right so we could represent the
factorization of the optimal matrix X
are you think sort of n times our
numbers plus and M times our numbers and
throughout this talk I'm gonna suppose
the M is order n so they're sort of
roughly the same size or let's imagine
the N is bigger than M ok so everything
says order and when it could be in order
you know min of a max of eminence ok so
when do we see first I want to justify
to you this is an interesting class of
problems so we should talk about when we
see these kinds of problems also I'm the
same basically the same ideas work for
the positive semi-definite case when X
is a symmetric positive semi definite
matrix and I'm not going to talk about
that case because it just makes things
more confusing but it's exactly the same
ok so on let's listen let's try to think
about whether we can achieve these goals
for this class and matrices so using a
first order method what would happen
right we look at the problem data and
then we'd have to write down the problem
variable so we could you know write it
down compute gradients compute
projections of it onto the constraint
right but soon as we write down the
variable we've got an order N squared
thing ok so this immediately
violates what we're trying to achieve so
our goal is to figure out how small can
we make the memory and still achieve a
global convergence right this is a
convex problem we think we should be
able to get the same guarantees that you
would expect from convex optimization
all right so so global convergence to
the global optimum okay
so what are some applications where you
might see this come up one might be a
matrix completion or this is a pretty
canonical problem at this point let's
suppose that I've observed I've got a
partially observed mate matrix M and so
I've observed the entries IJ and some
index set Omega and I want to matrix X
and matches M as close as possible on
those observed entries and I'm going to
add on some kind of a regularizer to
make sure that the X that I recover
isn't too complex it's gonna you know
hopefully give me a matrix X it's close
to the true matrix M so okay so in this
case ID is the number of observations or
is the number of entries of M that I've
seen and hey this linear operators going
to be the map that selects the observed
entrance finds the IJ's in omega and
here F is just the the square norm - the
swear knower of the opposite - the
observations so in other words the
things that we've observed are actually
implicit inside F we're hiding them
inside the function f okay so when is
this problem compact so has a compact
specification as long as the number of
observations is ordered n right so it's
like saying you've observed a constant
number of entries in every row or
constant number of entries in any column
you know for a case like matrix
completion where you're thinking these
are movie ratings that make sense right
most Watchers of movies have only
watched a constant number of movies
right the number of movies they watch
doesn't actually grow as the number of
movies growth and the solution is
compact if the rank of the optimum is
constant okay so oftentimes people will
um well they'll say things at this point
like the great white
I why do we expect that the rank of the
solutions to be concentrate they say
well we think that movie ratings should
be well approximated by a low rank
matrix because somehow every person
their preferences are described in terms
of the small number of parameters like
maybe there are a small number of genres
for every movie and the person's
preferences are you know only depending
on those genres but then you you come
across a different setting like I've got
a Word document matrix and people will
say oh maybe this word document matrix
is approximately low rank because there
aren't too many topics right so from how
for every new setting people cause at
some other kind of sort of simple kind
of underlying structure they should be
explaining why these things are low rank
and I had encountered enough
applications of this in like you know
even in like sort of hospitalization
records that turned out to be low rank
or responses on social surveys but it
started to make me feel a little bit
strange that I kept making this
assumption that there was some
underlying thing sort of simple
structure about the world that caused
things to be low rank and so on so we
right so so so so you can ask right why
why do you think there is a good
approximation to M with consummate rank
like isn't that a little bit I mean
right for any sort of generic data
matrix that seems like a kind of strong
thing to say so it turns out that you
can actually prove that this should be
true under relatively weak assumptions
there's something almost like this so
I'm actually gonna do it this is a quick
aside not part of the sketchy decisions
just to tell you why you should think
that things are approximately low rank
okay under a relatively simple model so
let's suppose that our data table a is
generated by a latent variable model
okay so what does that mean that means
that for every row we're gonna draw some
latent variable iid from some
distribution for every column we'll draw
some other latent variable iid from some
distribution see if draw what I'm
talking about so I thought M rows and
columns for every row I've got some
latent variable drawn iid for every
column I've got some latent variable
drawn iid
and the entries in this matrix are just
some function applied to latent variable
for the row and latent variable for the
column okay so if that function we're an
inner product and these guys were low
dimensional right then this would
automatically be a low rank
factorization and this would be a low
rank matrix okay but if these things are
sort of arbitrarily high dimensional and
this function is like an arbitrary
function then there's no reason to
believe that this is low rank okay and
so that's sort of exactly right the
assumption people make it they think
this is low dimensional and this is an
inner product and that seems kind of
implausible okay but this is a lot more
general okay so in order to prove
anything I need to make a couple of
technical assumptions I don't think
they're too strong so let's suppose that
these distributions and be a bounded
support and that this function G is
piecewise analytic and on each piece the
derivatives grow faster than
exponentially in the order of the
derivative okay so any polynomial a
bounded degree satisfies this expo many
polynomial bound a degree satisfies this
so most kernels that you might use so if
we think it's pretty general okay so
suppose we're in the setting and the
question is how does the rank of an
epsilon approximation to this matrix a
grow as the size of the matrix grows so
it's m and n grow right we can generate
more and more matrices from this model
from the same latent variable model
right how does the rank of this thing
grow an approximation to the rink and
the sense in which we want to
approximate it here is the sense of it's
actually this is kind of a strong sense
of approximation right the Infinity norm
so we want to approximate every entry to
within Epsilon okay so how large do you
think the rate should be in terms of MN
and Epsilon
how fast should the rank grow well I
mean certainly the rank is right it's
always bounded by the men of eminence
okay but like love okay so you want it
to be log of the sum of the side lengths
over epsilon is great excellent
excellent
right so the rank great grows as the log
of the sum of the sidelights right so
the one over epsilon squared is sort of
unfortunate for a data table perspective
it's not so bad because usually you
don't expect to be able to approximate
someone's rating for a movie to within
like 0.001 like point point one would be
pretty good okay so as the side length
Rose you get the rank of growing is the
log of the sum of the side lengths which
I know the log isn't the same as
consonant rank but it's you know what's
a log between friends so the our
statement of this is that nice latent
variable models our log rank okay so
this makes me feel a lot more
comfortable assuming that every data
table I've ever seen is approximately
low rank as long as the size of the data
table is large enough okay so that's an
addendum okay right but just
justification for why I believe that we
should be able to find solutions that
are better low rank okay um here's a
totally different application once we're
going back to this compact matrix
optimization problem so we're gonna
throw that we've got an image with n
pixels which I'm going to call X natural
so it's gonna live in a complex vector
space and the way that I'm going to
apply our measurements of this image is
that I'm going to be able to take inner
product so the image with some vector AI
it might be a Fourier transform at a
particular frequency and I'm going to
measure the blue norm squared of that
plus some noise okay so these
measurements don't look linear but
there's a easy trick to make them look
linear in some other space so I can
relax so if let's suppose that I have
this matrix X it's just X natural x
natural star so Rank 1 matrix and then I
can rewrite this observation so I'd when
I expand it out rewrite it using the
trace and then use the the cyclic
permutation variance of the trace
to find that it's a trace of a I story I
times this wrinkle in matrix X okay and
so this is nice because this is a linear
measurement on X ok so I can rewrite my
whole problem in terms of this big
matrix X rather than the original image
X natural and suddenly my observations
are linear in my new variable and the
cost is that now my variable is this
matrix variable instead of a 1
dimensional vector n dimensional vector
so if I solve this problem and at the
end I get a vector in RN write a rank
one matrix then I can actually figure
out from that rank one matrix what x
natural is right so the solution isn't
rank one then maybe I'm not even so
interested in the solution at all
actually um so if you talk to people who
actually do a face variable right they
they look at this kind of measurement
often so often the the let me you say so
the number of measurements that you
would take is something like four or
five times the dimension of the signal N
and it turns out that the ranks that we
were getting for these solutions turned
out to be like five and there's a turns
out to be a very good reason for that
which is that we're not actually using
the Fourier transform we're using the
discrete Fourier transform and there's
some discretization error introduced
every time you discretize taking your
picture of your city of your image of
your sort of actual substrate at a
different angle and so the
discretization error is different for
each sort of order n picture that you
collect so it's like for each
discretization area you get one rank one
matrix so if you took sort of five fit
pictures at different angles you get a
rank five matrix so it's actually the
the fact that it's not rank one is like
actually kind of fundamental to the
problem so I mean either case the rank
of the solution is constant and it's
compact if the number of observations is
order n and and I guess the hope is
right you shouldn't have to acquire you
know many more observations in the
number of pixels you're trying to
recover right sort of
you should expect that the number of
observations you would need would grow
linearly with the with the size of the
thing you're trying to reconstruct okay
so sort of generally what are some
reasons why we'd expect a compact matrix
optimization problem well one is the
data is expensive and so we'd want to
collect sort of a constant amount of
data sort of per row or a column and
then the second is that right so if the
solution is compact rather than a
compact specification should suffice
right we should be able to use sort of
order the same amount of data as the
size of the solution and then why should
we expect a compact solution on the
other side so the usual explanation is
like the world is simple and structured
but it turns out we don't have to make
that assumption we can just say well
maybe my data comes from an isolating
variable model and those are
approximately log-rank there's another
justification you can give which is that
for an es VP if the SDP has D
constraints then there is a solution
with rank order square root of D now
square root is even more unlike constant
than log but it's something okay so what
do we mean by optimal storage how low a
storage could we expect so we're gonna
assume right to sort of make things
concrete then we've got a black box
implementation of this operator a so
that means someone else is implementing
a for us we don't care what they're
doing but we're going to need to be able
to apply a to a rank one matrix or apply
a conjugant to a vector and then take
the inner products take them so that the
result of that is a matrix and then
apply that matrix to things on the left
and things on the right okay so it's
sort of at the rate those are all the
three operations you could possibly
imagine doing that a so we'll need to be
able to do each of them which means we
need enough storage for the inputs and
outputs of those operations okay so
we'll need at least order
ambos n plus D storage just to apply the
linear map and then on the other side if
we expect to rank our solution right
we'll need at least order R times n plus
n storage just to write down the
solution so sort of optimal storage
would be storage to know more than that
so the means of working storage should
be order D plus R times M plus
okay so that's that's what we're
shooting for okay so um right we know we
can specify the problem using order n
bits of storage floating points numbers
can we solve the problem using older
only order n floating-point numbers and
and you should remember if we ever write
down the variable right before it's low
rank we've already failed so we have to
solve the optimization problem without
writing down the variable that we're
optimizing over okay so I how do other
people solve these kinds of problems
this is a sorry a very brief and biased
history of matrix optimization so in the
90s you probably would have used
interior point methods for this kind of
problem but those the story scales
extremely poorly for that kind of method
in the 2000s people started using convex
first order methods much more like
accelerated proximal gradient and other
sort of similar methods and these do
require you writing down the matrix
variable so using a few gradients and
practice of it more recently there's
been a renewed interest in low memory
methods and there's sort of two
different approaches that people have
taken one is to try to look for storage
efficient first order optimization
methods one of the main approaches here
is to use the conditional gradient
method also called the Frank wolf method
and I this has a nice property that
every iteration the update to your
current iterate is ranked one so it
means that the rank of the iterate is
bounded by the number of iterations so
if we've done T iterations the the rate
the the the storage cost has been T
times ten plus n so that's nice except
that these methods converge really
slowly for this class of problems they
have like a 1 over epsilon convergence
rate so usually you expect that the
number of iterations is going to be
quite large by the way so enough people
have asked me this that I should clarify
so if your loss is strongly convex
you've got a strongly convex function of
a linear function if your constrain
for polyhedral then you get linear
convergence for Frank wolf but our
constraints RSVP constraints not
polyhedral constraints so we do get the
slow rate not the fast rate for Frank
wolf okay so so we need these number of
iterations can be large so there are
variants on this um you can do things
like pruning the factorization like
trying to find maybe rank 1 components
you've added but aren't so important or
you can actually see craic reducing
steps so you can consider a bunch of
different possible update directions and
try to go in 1 that reduces the rank
rather than increasing it and those are
some problems they work quite well but
you can't guarantee that they will
always work well so we don't like there
can be problems where the rank actually
grows quite high and we have seen that
in practice okay so the other major
approach to this kind of problem would
be non-contact heuristics so what those
do is they take the matrix variable and
they factor it and they rewrite the
problem in terms of this factored
variable and suddenly the problem I mean
it actually it usually becomes a smooth
optimization problem so it's quite fast
to just do gradient descent you often
converge linearly to the solution but
you can't guarantee that you will
converge to the global solution because
you've written down the right your
problem is now non convex and I'll show
you some examples where we actually
tried pretty hard to get these methods
to work and they were not able to sort
of find what looks like the right
solution on this on this problem so but
they work well under statistical
assumptions you can prove they work well
but if you're just given some data right
some some you know biologist says here I
have this you know data that I took with
my microscope you know please
reconstruct for me the image you can't
guarantee that these measurements obey
the statistical assumptions that you
need and indeed they sometimes fail in
bad ways where's the convex methods are
robust right this is one of the things
that people like about context methods
so it seems like the convex methods are
slow memory hogs but they have
guarantees and the non convex methods
are fast and lightweight but brittle and
we want the best of both worlds
okay so um the method that I will be
telling you about is based on the
conditional gradient method Frank wolf
so what does that look like so you
started to enter a text e um you take a
step you compute the gradient of the
objective at X T so this is a negative
gradient direction you go as far as
possible in the negative gradient
direction well staying inside the
constraint set which here's this shat in
one norm ball that point that extreme
point is your update direction and you
move in the update direction so that's
the right that's the way that this
method looks so here I'm just writing it
down in math compute the gradient that
the search compute the search Direction
choose a step size and then go in the
direction of that certain by an amount
of the step size okay so um okay so
there are two things that are sort of
worth remarking on one is that you you
need to be able to efficiently compute
the solution to this problem which is
just a linear optimization problem so
minimize a linear function over the
constraint set or if you can't do that
easily then you should not be using the
conditional gradient method and the
second is that you can actually compute
a bound on the sub optimality so this in
terms of computable quantities like the
update direction and the current iterate
so that provides a really nice stopping
criterion you can tell when you're
within epsilon of optimality a objective
function optimality which which you
can't do for the non convex method so
this is actually really nice okay so
what about the search Direction how do
we compute the search Direction
efficiently well okay so if I want I
want a an X that has bounded sum of
singular values that will be go as far
as possible in some particular direction
it has a maximum inner product with
something so the way to do that is I
look at the largest singular value of
the matrix negative G right and I should
just go in that direction right so I
should take the largest singular vector
if G right and I put everything I have I
put in that direction
okay so it turns out in the solution to
this is always rank one and you can
compute it gets by computing the maximum
singular vector of G so for us that's
really nice because it means we don't
need to write down G we only in between
able to compute its maximum singular
vector right which we could do using
like a launch s method right so just
applying it to vectors and applying its
conjugate to vectors so we wouldn't have
to ever write down G which is good
because G is an N by M by n thing so we
can't write down G ok so so far things
are looking promising so here's what the
algorithm looks like so we start with an
initial X for every iteration we can be
at the maximum singular vector of the
gradient we say that that is our update
direction we evaluate the stopping
condition and we take the step okay but
we need to get rid of right we're not
allowed to write down X right so we're
gonna need to get rid of X so what's
interesting is that for this algorithm
you can do that so they're tube there's
big ideas that we're gonna be using one
is to use this low dimensional dual
variable they applied to X to drive the
iterations rather than keeping track of
X will keep track of Z the second idea
is that we're gonna recover the solution
is from promote small randomized sketch
of X okay so this this is the origin of
the name sketchy decisions we're
sketching the decision variable the the
name of the game is right we can't write
down X until it's already low rank so
we're gonna look at this problem and
every time we see X it turns out there's
an A in front of it okay so every time
we see an m-by-n thing there's an A in
front of it
in fact even here right I'm I'm writing
down H which is an N by n thing but once
I actually use it there's an A in front
of it ok and here right I'm updating X
but since I only use a times X right I'm
as much as well not update X but update
a times X I'm giving you the gory
details because otherwise it seems like
magic and I like it if right you it's
not magic okay so I'm gonna replace all
the a XS with Z's okay and I replace
right so a a
I just apply a to this Rank 1 matrix and
that's one of the blackbox Oracle's that
I I said I could rely on okay
so I've gotten rid of anything that's
order MN right this is right I am I am
computing the iterates of this algorithm
are exactly the same as the previous one
and I've gotten rid of everything that's
order M times n okay so it's just
ordered right order and storage right
here
the in turrets are the same the
objective values are exactly the same
it's just the same algorithm the only
problem is that when I'm done I don't
have the solution right I don't have X
here right and you might hope that I
could just recover X from Z but that's
not always possible so think about the
matrix completion case where you can
exactly complete the matrix if you can
exactly complete the matrix that means
that the solution Z is actually 0 ok but
if I tell you right here's here's order
and entries and in this matrix now
exactly complete this matrix just tell
me what the rest is that's right that's
it I think that's why you're solving the
problem to begin with right that's not
that's a hard problem so just because
you tell me you can exactly complete it
doesn't tell me what the answer is and
I'm in the same situation here just
because you tell me Z doesn't mean I can
figure out what X is so we've solved the
problem we need to find the solution I
feel like it's a strange situation to be
in
ok so here's where the second idea comes
in we're gonna sketch the solution and
since the entire morning was on
sketching you now now now know how to
sketch extremely well so you know there
are a wide variety of sketches you might
use depending on your circumstances I'm
gonna give you a particular example but
the basic idea is very simple we know
that the solution is gonna be a low rank
matrix and lauric matrices are like they
don't have too many parameters right so
if we if we find a matrix X right right
so X hat but it sort of acts like X star
all right an X star you know doesn't do
that many complex things it's just a low
rank matrix then then we actually have X
star
this meant to be like the the quote you
know if it walks like a duck and talks
like a duck than it is a duck call me
for low rank matrices
okay so we're gonna see a series of
additive updates we're gonna remember
how the matrix acts and we're gonna
reconstruct a low rank matrix that acts
like X okay so what does that look like
this is like the simplest possible
sketch that you can come up with you can
make it fancier it doesn't actually help
you very much in this context so we're
gonna drop two independent standard
normal matrices each one is going to be
sort of dimensions observe one one one
side of our matrix times something
that's order R order the rank so
constant okay these are just so it's a
random Gaussian matrices and the sketch
consists of two matrices that are gonna
try to capture the range and the co
range of X so if I multiply X by this
random Gaussian matrix on the right
right every column in the resulting
matrix Y is gonna be in the range of X
and the hope is that these columns
actually span the full range of X so I
can reconstruct the range of X from the
columns of Y and and that's true as long
as you know Omega is sort of with high
probability as long as Omega is chosen
randomly and and K is larger than R so
which it is and then we'll do the same
thing with the rows so we'll we'll
writes I times X and that means that the
rows of W should capture the the row
space of X the like that should be
enough right it's a low rank at the end
rate of X or a low rank matrix this
should be enough to figure out what it
was okay so since we're not seeing X
right not seeing X star we're seeing
these rank-1 updates to X star it turns
out that these rank-1 updates we can
perform on the sketch instead of on the
matrix itself so if we're adding and
make Rank 1 matrix X we can update the
sketch by applying that main rank one
matrix on the left to Omega and on the
right to sy and these are both easy
things right we don't have to form this
M by n matrix we just apply sy to you
and then apply the result to be
okay so both the storage costs for the
sketch and the arithmetic cost of this
procedure are all order R times M plus M
so right there all allowed okay so to
recover the rank R approximation from
the sketch what we're gonna do is three
pretty simple operations we'll do a
skull skinny QR we're gonna do a small Q
R plus a back substitution and then a
tall skinny SVD so all of these
operations are order like order M plus n
there's nothing m times n about them and
there's a thing we need a quadratic in R
so the result you can prove about this
is the following so if you sketch a
matrix X and you reconstruct it using
this procedure what you'll get is a rank
R matrix X hat that satisfies the
following guarantee the expectation
right over the way that you chose the
random rate the random sketch of X minus
X hat and for B Gnaeus norm is less than
twice the difference between a storm of
the difference between X and the best
rank R approximation to X ok so I'm and
this to actually you can make it as
small as you want by choosing the sketch
wide enough but for us to is good enough
I guess it's worth remarking when X is
actually rank R then this right hand
side is 0 and so that means the left
hand side is 0
so that's cool I'm Ashley so so what's
weird so after we figured this out we
found that there's a woodruff david
whatever i've had previously written
down sort of a procedure that's almost
the same it sort of took a while to
reconstruct they were the same they were
sort of hidden move algebraically the
same but not numerically the same so
when we tried implementing his method
like the the we just weren't getting the
results that we needed for this
optimization result whereas if we just
did a little bit more careful of
numerical analysis the results improved
a lot so it's sort of interesting
noticing the write the things that write
the TCS community cares about and the
things that like numerical and the
analysts care about and write even when
we're interested in the same problem
somehow we don't necessarily speak the
same language but I think it's really
cool that there's this sort of
connection all the way through here ok
so um
I'm gonna give you intuition for why the
sketch works okay
so um I mean it's quite simple okay so
suppose you had an orthonormal basis Q
for the range of X okay well then
clearly X is QQ star times X all right
it's a basis for the range of X okay
okay so um but we don't have a basis for
the range of X to begin with what we can
do is we can take this sketch of the
range of X right X times Omega alright
that was the thing that was supposed to
span the same range as as X and we can
do a QR decomposition on that so that
hew we're really hoping that Q still
spans the range of X we're hoping that Q
is the basis for the range of X okay
okay so then also if we have the the
sketch of the Co ring so W is sy times X
right so W the rows of W were supposed
to span the rows of X we'll rewrite this
right because we know the X is
approximately equal to Q Q star contacts
and so we'll look at this and we'll say
well that means that if I if I take the
pseudo-inverse I times Q this is a small
matrix it's like an order R by order R
matrix and I will pseudo-inverse
so I'll I'll bring it over to the other
side and I guess I get this thing is
about equal to Q star times X so that
means we can reconstruct X using X is
equal to Q times Q star times X by just
applying Q to both sides and these are
all things that we know how to compute
so what's really cool about this right
is that I don't need to I don't need to
like learn something about X in order to
know which entries of X I need to
collect right I can just collect a
random sketch of X from the beginning
and so that's what it allows me to sort
of combine it with this optimization
algorithm that has the additive updates
right I don't you know so I can't say I
can't for example sample proportional to
the diagonal of the matrix sample sort
of off diagonals proportional but it
diagonal because they don't know what
the diagonal is going to be in the end
right so it's really important that I
have this linear sketch no single path
sketch okay um let's get back to the
optimization picture
okay so I'm gonna add the sketch into
the optimization algorithm and it's not
changing the algorithm at all the
iterates are exactly the same nothing
changes all its happenings I'm
collecting some side information so at
every iteration I also update my sketch
using this sort of update direction and
saying how much I'm gonna update it the
step size and at the end I just
reconstruct the solution from the sketch
it satisfies the guarantees I told you
about earlier okay so um if I just
rewrite those guarantees in terms of the
you know the interests of this
conditional gradient method here's what
I get so let's let's say that X TCM is
the teeth iterative this conditional
gradient method the if I if I do sort of
the the floor with an R that's the best
rank R approximation to the CPM interet
and I'll say X hats upper T is the the
sketchy CM reconstruction that I would
make if I reconstructed after T
iterations to get the air and cheese I'm
not allowed to sort of constantly
reconstruct I have to decide when I'm
gonna reconstruct and then reconstruct I
can only do it once okay so after T
durations the reconstruction will
satisfy exactly the same value saw
before for this sketch which is just
that the expectation of the difference
between my reconstruction and the actual
iterate is less than twice the distance
between the actual iterate and the best
rank our approximation for the iterate
so in particular if the iterate is rank
R the right-hand side is zero so the
left-hand side is zero in other words I
have in hand the solution to my problem
that's cool okay so graphically what
does this look like um so let's look
this uh this this squiggly thing that's
going to be the manifold of rank less
than or equal to R matrices right I
don't think it actually looks like that
but I don't know how to draw it so we're
gonna start off on this manifold right
zero the zero matrix is on this manifold
and we believe that we're going to
converge back to this manifold in the
atoms right to the solution right the
the interest that that the CG emitter
'its are converging to is on this
manifold which I'll call X CEM
[Music]
hmm okay sure
okay so um right so so what I'm going to
sort of follow the iterates like I'm not
gonna write them down but I'm going to
kind of follow them and then at the end
when I get back to this man fold and I
reconstruct since it's on the manifold I
will exactly get X X hat is equal to XE
q okay but that's not usually what
happens right because I never get
exactly right I never I never iterate my
interative algorithm all the way to the
end instead I stop at some point right
so when I stop at some point right I
might not be at the solution which means
I'm not quite back to this manifold of
rank R matrices okay so in that case the
guarantee that I get is that the the
reconstruction that I make it's
definitely on Ray it's definitely a rank
R matrix it's definitely on this
manifold and the distance between it and
the last iterate is no more than twice
the distance between the best rank our
approximation and the last iterate so
that's the form of the guarantee that I
get okay
so I so there's this funny mismatch so
um at this point I can tell you about on
the sub at optimality of this point okay
but once I once I do this reconstruction
I can tell you how far it is in iterate
space so I know how close this is to the
solution in terms of objective value I
know how close this is to this in terms
of iterate space but to get a sort of
complete bound on either the objective
value or the distance to the solution I
would have to be able to either bound
the distance from this to the solution
or bound sort of how far this changes my
objective value and to do either of
those I'm going to need something like
strong convexity so if I assume
something like strong convexity then I
can give you a pound on how far my
reconstruction is from the optimal
iterate as a function of the iteration
counter okay but if I don't assume
something like strong convexity that I
can't get a I can't get a rate but I
think this is sort of the right um this
is the the sort of the correct rate in
spirit okay
so it's like a 1 over T right ok so
let's go back to the application this is
actually work well so we're back to our
phase retrievable application we've got
an image with n pixels we're gonna
require these noisy measurements of the
norm of the of the inner products
between some vectors and the pixels
we're gonna recover the image by solving
this compact matrix optimization problem
using a whole bunch of methods including
ours and the things we're interested in
are you know how fast is this method how
much memory does it use and also what
quality solution does it produce okay so
when we're comparing this oh so we think
it makes sense to comparison this is a
convex method we're gonna compare it to
the convex methods in terms of its
memory but of course all the convex
methods converge to the same solution so
it's not very interesting to say what
solution do they converge to I'll
compare to the non convex methods in
terms of what solution do they converge
to okay so if we compare it to a bunch
of different convex methods we see as
the length of the signal grows the
number of the amount of memory that the
algorithm uses also grows and ours grows
less quickly than all the others because
ours is growing linearly and most of the
others are growing quadratically so
that's not a surprise
indeed the convergence though the error
is a function of number of iterations
it's a it's a we do get a 1 over T rate
so this is a log-log plot and this is a
1 over T rate so unfortunately you know
it's it's not very fast we do require a
large number of iterations ok so more
interesting is to actually see how it
does on real data so here this is an
example from Fourier typography so this
is a particular kind of face retrieval
it's a bridge icon review what it means
is it's a particular kind of
experimental setup a particular kind of
microscope and kind of observations that
you get and here what we're doing is
we're imaging blood cells and we are
looking for malaria so the malaria is
gonna appear as sort of little white
bright patches on these blood cells so
the problem is large enough that we're
not able to apply the other convex
methods and I guess that's a little bit
interesting so we can run our method
the parameter are set to be like six or
maybe ten or something and when we do
this the the matrix that we reconstruct
right which is allowed to have rank up
to ten actually has rank five and that's
that's a right based on the sort of the
story that I told you before that that's
actually what you should expect because
of the way that you get this sort of
truncation error and the discrete
Fourier transform okay so if we compare
the results of running our method to
results of two non convex methods Brewer
Montero and Verde and your flow don't so
by the way we played around a lot with
these methods we tried quite hard we
like twiddle the parameters quite a bit
to try to get them to converge to nice
solutions and we weren't able to make
these like weird squiggly artifacts go
away like the ripples and we think
that's just because the problem is
pretty ill-conditioned and this is just
like the kinds of measurements here are
kind of terrible kinds of measurements
and these non-convex methods just don't
perform very well on this kind of
measurement where is the solution that
we get is actually sort of I'm smooth
decently resolved and so if you're
looking for these little malaria
squiggles so they're in here these
little white patches little white
patches it's kind of weird to look for
them here because the the ripples
actually look like a little white
patches so for the actual application I
mean you can argue about right which
picture looks better but I'd say the
convex method is is showing fact that
it's a little bit more stable more
robust than the non convex methods and
there are no parameters to twiddle like
just works um in fact alpha the the
bound on the the the bound alpha that
you need on the shat in one norm is
something that we have good theoretical
bands for okay so what's the right
what's the conclusion so this is really
just a proof of concept convex method
for a particular class of compact matrix
optimization problems and there are two
new ideas that really make this possible
one is to drive the algorithm
using a smaller dual variable and the
other is to be able to sketch and
recover the the decision variable from
this sketch so I mean ultimately I'd
hope that we could do this for a much
wider class of problems right there's no
reason why we shouldn't be able to do
this for like you know every SVP that I
know of right I mean I think it's a real
question right is does convex
optimization have a higher memory
requirements than non convex
optimization for the same sort of kinds
of problems and that's not yet clear
well thank you
[Applause]
have you ever tried combining sort of
what you're proposing and the non-convex
methods like in the month of XP that you
converge a stationary point from that is
by doing a run update we haven't so much
I think it's hard I mean just getting
the parameters right of like when you
should sort of take the convex step and
when you could take the non convex step
is a little bit tricky yeah or not I
mean know another way you can combine
them is you can run the convex method
for a while and then switch to the non
convex method that doesn't work so well
for us because we're not able to
reconstruct a low rank matrix until we
get pretty close to it
but I mean maybe that's how close you
have to be before the non convex methods
work but I think it's um it's often hard
to evaluate just on the basis of the
data rate without making assumptions
about what the data should look like how
close you have to be to the solution
before the non convex methods are going
to converge to the global optimum and so
that makes it hard to know when to
switch
yeah yeah okay I know you're suggesting
something a little bit different right
which is sort of expanding in the rank
until until you can go in the right
direction maybe this the contracts
methods can tell you what if you're
gonna add or rank one sort of matrix to
your current iterate what rank one
matrix should you add yeah I think
that's also quite interesting yeah so um
so basically we have hid those by just
using factors of two so if you want this
to to be a 1 plus epsilon then the these
like sort of K and L have to increase I
don't remember the precise dependence
because for us like 2 is really good
enough yeah yeah something
like also I mean um yeah I think that's
bigger than we want to go yeah I mean
we're like the idea here is that our is
consonant so square root of n is a lot
bigger than constant yeah just to see if
the if the Wiggles would go away I think
that's an interesting yeah that would be
fun to try yeah you have to do this kind
of power III to capture the range
um so I
so I mean you can certainly do better if
you can do some kind of power iteration
but like in practice you don't hear you
don't need to so depending on how
quickly your the tale of decays of the
singular values you can get you can
prove sort of tighter bounds of the tail
decays quickly than less quickly but I
mean you can get a decent approximation
even just using one pass thank you